I don't know why they're doing that I've
been out here for a while so sad
thanks so much for behaves really used
to that and that's a ridiculous thing to
say but you get that reaction when you
walk when I go to the supermarket exam
everywhere people she's making up a red
pepper yeah now it doesn't happen all
the time fortunately yeah I understand
you were just in New York City Andy and
I spent a lot of time in that city we
love that town you were just there
promoting this film how was it New York
how did it go he's great it was uh it
was a lot of fun I was staying in the
East Side which I love and then went to
see a friend Fred and one day on the
west side he said come on come on over
and visit me in my pad right in the West
Side Highway was break sided and bent
over there in a long time so I went over
there and got dropped off and I didn't
realize it was gay Pride Day was it was
it was it was like a hundred and fifty
thousand men all very excited I have to
be wearing tank top it is hot out during
a tank top I was yeah testicle shorted
and I'm urging you were wearing a big
mustache just cuz it was hot
and and then I got chased down the
street by the alarms I chased down the
street by a large man wearing a sock
around his shouting Captain Kirk is
[Applause]
quite a welcome to the city I think I
made it back to the hotel in 12 minutes
yeah that's so fussing first of all that
the guys out just wearing a socks yes
sees you and then it just has the
confidence to just go running after you
okay that was just like whoa and by
confidence you mean confidence in the
sock yes and its ability to stay on
probably glued it on that's what I do
more on that later you know just talking
to you right now I don't want to make
you self-conscious you have very
impressive eyebrows and I say that I'm
someone who has extremely light wispy
eyebrows you've got the real deal where
I have eye
they're like junior Peter Gallagher's
yes is the king of the eyebrow an
impressive set but I yeah and every foam
I do they're always trying to tone them
down they're always very nervous that
the eyebrows would be - I don't know -
just too much so those are distracting
it may be too distracting so occasion
they'll try to dye them which doesn't
ever really seem to work out how would
we emphasize them is they try to make
them flesh colored so it just looks like
right or forehead is that what's
happening right I already have I already
have quite a forehead as we speak so
between that and the bushy hair it's
just it's a lot of hair right here yeah
it's like it's a visor of hair was that
a thing that you were self-conscious
about when you were when you were
younger when you were a kid did people
give you a hard time about your eyebrows
notice really I never you know making
films are so weird because you make the
film and the cameras are so small
they're right here and then you go to a
theater and it's like it your face is 40
feet high yeah it's great so every
imperfection everything you might be
some conscious about is just like
glaring and blaring in your face so I
remember when I did the Princess Diaries
film the second one and it looked like
it it looked like I was wearing two
squirrels on my head wasn't the most
exciting experience to see my to see the
hair yeah it just makes you so trust me
you don't have to be self-conscious
about it I wish I envy you I wish we
could do a brow transplant because like
I say mine you have lovely brown no no
they they actually have to like they're
so light they blend in with my flesh
tone then you go just before I go out
it's wonderful you have that wonderful
curl you know what I do sometimes as I
bring this down and wrap it around
it's it's a lot of work